[Musique]
jean lassalle ne s'alimente plus depuis
16 jours nous vous avions parlé au début
de sa grève de la faim du combat mené
par ce député de pyrénées atlantiques au
sein même de l'assemblée nationale qui
suscitait et moqueries ou indignation de
la part de ses pairs au fil des jours
pourtant sa détermination ébranle les
plus sceptiques jean lassalle protestent
contre le départ d'une usine située dans
sa circonscription catherine de mange à
christelle jorion
ils ont tous un mot un geste de
sympathie qu'on lui au 16e jour de sa
grève de la faim jean lassalle inquiète
ses collègues députés de droite ou de
gauche chacun voudra le convaincre de
renoncer
je t'ai dit que ce n'était pas le
meilleur moyen pour aboutir mais
aujourd'hui inquiet pour sa santé depuis
16 jours le député udf des pyrénées
atlantiques ne quitte plus ce canapé de
la salle des quatre colonnes une grève
de la faim ses larmes ultime qui l'a
choisi pour protester contre la
délocalisation d'une usine japonaise
implanté dans sa circonscription 150
emplois sont menacés je ne pouvais pas
supporter cette situation là
alors ce n'est pas un acte d'impuissance
c'est pas un acte de désespoir quand
quelqu'un se jette à l'eau pour un saut
vers nantes il n'est pas désespérée il a
peur peut-être enfants de milieux que
cette note d'espoir qui pose en cause
cette entreprise de la vallée d'aspe
sociale les responsables du groupe
veulent déplacer son activité à une
soixantaine de kilomètres dans le bassin
de lacq pour eux il ne s'agit pas de
délocalisation qu'est ce qu'on a fait
nous on a on a créé sans emploi en vingt
ans on s'est développée gentiment on
veut se développer on a notre stratégie
on veut nous empêcher de faire notre
stratégie mais ces outils quoi jean
lassalle lui continue son combat
rien ne l'arrête pas même les
engagements pris aujourd'hui même par le
ministre de l'économie pour maintenir
l'emploi dans la vallée das fatigué mais
d'éternuer problème c'est pas ça
qui manque de sucre puis le tour de tout
le truc il faut habituellement donc là
je risque de faire des syncopes et si
j'en fais une jolie devrait il me met à
l'hôpital
je veux pas y aller
marquée par l'épreuve jean lassalle va
se reposer dans son bureau de
l'assemblée demain il entamera son 17e
jour de grève de la faim
[Musique]